JEN PERSON: Today, we're
talking about Google Cloud Next.
I'm Jen Person, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news
from the safety of our home.
Google Cloud Next
OnAir begins next week.
This digital interpretation
of our annual conference
will offer nine
weeks of programming
to help you solve
your toughest business
challenges in the cloud.
And the best part
is you can join in
for free, no matter
where you are
and at a time that
works for you.
Be sure to register
beforehand so that you
can build a customized
playlist of the content
you're interested in.
In the session
catalog, you can filter
by speaker, topic, or
industry, so you can
be sure not to miss a thing.
Each week, during
Next, we'll be adding
a new batch of breakout sessions
you can watch on demand.
We've also got a lineup
of digital demos,
weekly hands-on challenges, and
even a unique learning series.
And if you need a
bit more support,
you can book a 15-minute
one-on-one appointment
with a cloud expert.
For the duration of the
event, "This Week in Cloud"
will be covering
highlights and sessions
you won't want to miss.
Each episode will
introduce that week's theme
and then give you a preview of
some of our favorite content.
If you want to read more
about Google Cloud Next,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment, or tweet us.
And we'll see you in the cloud.